the title this this video should be can
we have this the turn this video should
be how not to store passwords thank you
um because you you really shouldn't
store passwords yourself if you can all
avoid it if you are running any kind of
web service and and you are storing
passwords it is so incredibly easy to
get it wrong that basically you
shouldn't try um if you can use sign in
with Facebook or Twitter or Google and
get them to handle it for you for crying
out loud please do if you're a web
programmer sooner or later you're gonna
have to store passwords and this is this
is the ways not to do it if you aren't
other ways to do it I will kind of say
that at the end but for please please
please please look up a recent tutorial
for the language you're using by the
time you watch this video the advice
will have changed you may be watching
this years in the future look up a
tutorial that's been written in the last
few months by someone reputable and
follow that how do you not store
passwords the first instinct the naive
thing
[Music]
he's just store the users password so
let's say you have a sign-up box and you
have a user name and password box
the naive things that when the user
signs up you take their password and you
store it in the database as it is in
plain text that has a couple of
advantages first of all if they forget
their password you could just email it
to them and it means that you know
checking it is really simple when they
log in again you take their username you
take their password and then you take
what they've just typed you compare it
to what's in the database and if it
matches you let them in and that is the
the naive approach to storing passwords
there are still professional websites
out there run by big corporations that
still use this strategy and you can tell
that using this strategy because they
email your password back to you in plain
text when you ask for it um this is a
monumentally bad idea this is this is an
astonishingly bad idea because if
someone gets into your database through
a security hole or because they're an
insider with access and let's be honest
if you're storing passwords this way you
probably have other security holes too
um then they can just read out every
user and their password so you have
their email address and you have their
password and let's be honest most people
reuse the same password for their email
address on websites so this is a bad
idea
because it's incredibly insecure
approach number two
slightly that's naive still a bad idea
if you take that password and you
encrypt it so you you hide it behind
something an encryption is two-way so
encryption is something that you have a
key that will lock something and then
unlock it again so the naive approach is
you take the user's password you take it
into your database encrypted like this
behind you know thing you've locked and
then as Cheney's hand when they log in
again you take what they've got you go
here you unlock this you compare them
and then you let them in now that's a
little bit more secure because if
someone just reads out the database
you've got an encryption key there but
it's got a couple of big floors first of
all as soon as that Keys available the
passwords still visible and can still be
read out and it means that an insider or
even a hacker in some cases can just
take the encryption key as well with
them and they've still got access to all
the passwords that's a pretty bad idea
the other floor with this is that if you
have lots of people using the same
password and if you've got a big site
this will happen because lots of people
will use one two three four five six or
password one and if I just said either
of your YouTube passwords go change it
if you have that all the encryption will
be the same so even if you don't have
the encryption key you can still tell
that all these people have the same
password so it's probably a common one
Adobe just made this mistake this month
as we record this and don't be the big
company behind Acrobat which makes PDFs
behind Photoshop behind all the big
tools millions and millions and millions
of users their password database got
breached gigabytes of passwords lost but
it's fine they set yours yet mine was as
well fortunately I didn't use that
password anywhere else which is what you
should hopefully be doing their
passwords were encrypted and that was it
it was just a you know a lock on it and
it meant that everyone had the same
password had the same encrypted code
unfortunately also stored all the
password
hints with them which is which is
wonderful because then you can look oh
look there's 20 people who've used the
same password here and that one says
Michael Jackson is the password hint and
that one says Halloween and that one
says type of movie oh look it's Thriller
okay wonderful it's Thriller and that's
one of the biggest software companies in
the world didn't do this properly um
anyway so don't use encryption naive
attempt number three hashing now I've
talked about this in an earlier video um
a hash is a summary of a load of data so
let's say you have the password the user
enters and you know that and when they
enter it you're gonna hash it are you
gonna put it through some kind of
convolutions that ends up like that and
then when the user enters their password
again you takes it in the same way
compare devastate which is great in
theory but unfortunately if you open the
same problem that Adobe hat which is
that if you can tell a common password
if it's in loads of people's database
entries you probably can work out what
it is worse than that as I've said
before Google has an index of these
things if you're using a basic hashing
algorithm you can pretty much just type
the code into Google and it will give
you the password back as well as just
searching for common hashes on Google
there are these things called rainbow
tables which trade off computation time
for hard drive space so rather than
having to calculate millions and
millions of hashes for this one password
someone has already done it for you
calculated past but account allotted
hashes for billions of common passwords
and just put them out in a database
it's gigabytes long but it's a lot
easier to search through that than it is
to try and do a load of calculation so
if you're using something common like
md5 or sha-1 with nothing else added the
rainbow table will pretty much help you
crack that in a few seconds I have in
the past used all those nowyou've
approaches myself on things I've built
in my youth I've gone back and fixed
them where they're still alive and just
have quietly buried the code
we're what they weren't but the approach
nowadays is to use something called
hashing and salting as I said the best
thing is not to store passwords at all
but if you have to the advice these days
is hash salt so salt is a random string
of characters that is different for
every single user
it's a password you know in your
database in storage in plain text it
doesn't matter the user could even know
it not that it would help them with
anything that means when the user
registers they put the password in and
it goes into the same algorithm but as
well as that you generate a random
string of characters for each user
completely random a new second password
if you'd like that goes in the database
and that gets fed into this algorithm
too so that comes in mutates it a bit
more comes out with something else so if
another user uses the same password that
algorithm will get a completely
different salt from them some people
might based on the username that's
generally a bad thing to do it should
just be a random string of characters so
the same password going in for a
different user will mutate into
something entirely different the point
of this is that now you just have a
random string for each user you cannot
possibly pull the password back from
this it won't appear in Google because
it's a massively long random string you
can't brute-force it back by looking at
what common passwords are reused all you
can do is do the old-style attack of
trying every single common password one
after the other and if your salts long
enough and your hashing algorithm is
complicated enough then that's really
incredibly difficult to do do it right
and it's lifetime of the universe
difficult to do or at least it is until
they use the password one two three four
five six
if you change one bite one bit anywhere
in the file at the start of the middle
at the end then the whole hash should be
completely different this is something
called the avalanche effect this very
complex signal is not just dependent on
the bit pattern that was last written to
the drive but it actually depends on
what was there previously